what it's going home people happy Friday
John and I have been editing and filming
for patreon and stuff we didn't put up
anything on YouTube so we thought it'd
be fun to go live let's wait for someone
to be here and I'm gonna repeat all this
information what's up Juan incognito
rich how you guys doing so guys catch us
up on movie news that's on your mind and
so we'll talk about it because yeah we
didn't put up anything today hey
everyone
John your karate your crush is here your
crush is here your crushes oh what's up
what it jump hook put the live on the
yeah there you go there you go
yeah yeah right there let's get the chat
on the computer so we can make sure
we're not missing any questions Houser
Friday go and everyone thanks della
I think we're both looking really good
Hannah me too kind
is this about Sonic being pushed back
hey sonic being pushed back did you hear
about that who wouldn't have seen that
coming
Jon pay attention to stream what are you
doing you're just looking at stuff
online looking as we're gonna porn right
now we're live John hello John how old
this John look alright in 2020 we're
doing this man you're blushing oh where
where do you live Amy ownio John ever
since I stopped pulling the phone we
have lost 45 people in this chat what
the hell did you say well I was gone I
okay so alright so sonic sonic the
hedghog being not be present I just
wanted to know what's the date one cares
they're pushing it back because the
reanimating in John but I want to know
how this is what it's like when we're
not filming
what bush it's any amount of time would
be good right now yeah of course they're
pushing it back man they got to
reanimate the whole thing because all
you guys are unhappy with it this is
your fault everyone who's in this
livestream I blame you for us Sonic is
being pushed back now we don't get it so
upset and so upset 11 minutes past
midnight you should be sleep or you know
the finding ways to go to sleep let's
see here burning Godzilla Oh what's up
in Paraguay come on
fourth Matrix movie I do not want them
to do a fourth Matrix movie I do not I
think I'm a defender of the Matrix
trilogy I like them all even the third
one John what's your take I'm right
there with you I
I appreciate the trilogy I just I'm sure
somebody out there has a brilliant place
they can take a matrix for but I don't
have a lot of faith that we live on the
timeline where that's really gonna
happen I would at most like to see some
kind of maybe anthology or something
shepherded by the witch house please I
just I don't really want more matrix
great yeah but a matrix for man so John
I keep profile the whole time oh dude
I'm gonna yeah I'm more to engage with
the people I've got the chat here if
Taron Egerton was cast as penguin I
would not like no you need a creepy dude
oh yeah I mean I feel like if you cast
Tara deserts in his penguin then you
would just have to cover him and so much
makeup and costuming and really make him
completely different God like I feel
like he's got good after acting jobs but
yeah I would be it's liked about that
Tyko ytt is directing got official
release date for 2021 for a Kyra that's
exciting I feel like that's cool I mean
he does Thor Ragnarok and now we all
want to see him do
like crazy weird [ __ ] so why not I mean
I've cured on my list of what to watch I
mean catch up on anime I've been
watching Death Note and then after death
note I'm gonna start up Akira yeah
that's just about watching my hometown
we're not doing reactions for it but
yeah I think that's real some really
cool news man tiger which I could
totally pull that [ __ ] off I guess I'm
very curious as to how he let that kick
I'd be like you know Ragnar odd proves
he can work in a big world and I'm sure
that was a big part of it but from my
understanding his Sensibility like I'm
excited to see him branch out because I
understand that Akira is in no way a
comedy but I am also like oh wow so
Carter Lovejoy thanks for the super chat
buddies mate he says thoughts on Rotten
Tomatoes changing their algorithm
audience score with verification they
should because that [ __ ] even people
can really manipulate that they can make
it easily people are voting all the time
too without even seeing the damn things
and because of that element hey jab eco
a we are planning on reacting to your
vlog later yeah because of what was the
question said yeah no they should they
should they should definitely I should
definitely be changing it up because
that thing has been abused and abused
over and over again and I feel like oh I
go off audience score more than I go off
critics score a lot of the time too so
for someone like me personally I think
it's a great idea yeah to update that
John I think it'll be clunky at first
and figuring out all the nuts and bolts
of making it a smooth apparatus but I
think it's definitely something that
ought to have been done because you know
you shouldn't get anybody abusing the
system in any direction thank you god
just sour oh s--- for that little super
out there your sexy ganja thank you yeah
yeah I don't know I think it's
definitely a great idea though because
especially after some of the ugliness
we've seen of people manipulating it and
you know we already have IMDB scores to
be ridiculous so I think this is for the
good altum Utley and I
just hope that they get it smooth you
know yeah that's true yeah
so someone what are the questions that
we got what questions do we got I'm just
I'm just going as long as whatever pops
up after I'm done speaking most
anticipated movie as of now once upon a
time in Hollywood easily once upon a
time in Hollywood that health thanks
Lance that's sweet
once upon a time in Hollywood any time
Tarantino I don't even need to see a
trailer and I'm like easily most
anticipated movie you got Al Pacino in
there in a Tarantino flick that's enough
to something that one actor is enough to
sell me to combined with that director
working with Quentin Tarantino I'm
thinking of starting petitions for
movies just anytime I have a slight
issue with something I'm starting a
petition to change act one of Aladdin
because that was my biggest issue with
petitions just to fix little notes I had
for stuff hey guys Jack away has a vlog
that he worked his ass off on you guys
should go check it out as soon as you
can we will be reviewing bright burn
we're shooting our review tomorrow we
both watched it yesterday we have a
friend coming by who knows the director
of photography so I didn't know if he
give any extra input but you know I
wanted to shoot something with him then
I we always talk movies so I thought be
cool the review bright burn with him so
you guys will have to wait on that it'll
probably be up on Sunday but yeah John
liked it a little more than me
that's the tease to our review to say
that I'll say that no no no I wouldn't
say it sucks have you heard this
somebody wanted to know if we've heard
this rumor about the Batman scripts
being about Bruce trying to hunt down
the killer of his parents and how we
feel about that sure why the [ __ ] not we
live in a world of speculation for all
these things you know we'll dissect
anything any theory that comes any
reddit user says some [ __ ] and we wanted
like [ __ ] dissect the hell out of it
somebody could have just written this on
a napkin
I don't know I just I feel like that
does lend itself to a personal detective
story sure that works I'd rather wait
for official news but right now that
idea doesn't sound exactly exciting to
me but yeah whatever is the way we
overhaul our YouTube channel just start
reporting anything we want about Batman
because right now in the speculation
phase I mean people are gonna believe
any I mean is he going to I kind of want
to want him to know who his parents
killers are you know what I mean
I've always liked it when you didn't
know for sure well we've seen him in
other you know iterations find Joe Chill
and stuff like that like I don't know so
is the idea that he's already been
Batman for a while and then he decides
you know what I'm gonna go look for this
guy's killed my parents is that it
because I thought he's supposed to be
Batman for a while at this point yeah
then after laws like yeah screw it let's
do it because Oh too bright too bright
guys too bright too dark
do you see that John is just a ghost do
you want to see a scream five no I know
I want to see you I think if you did is
in there moving like five to ten years
would be cool especially with the how
horror has constantly seems to be adapt
and adapting in cinema so I I do think
that would be neat to see what
commentary social commentary they can
make on it are you ready to see Godzilla
we're watching a Tuesday night what we
do reactions to Watchmen when it airs
well wait to see what people say I feel
like it I don't know if it'd be exciting
reactions that seem but to kind of show
you be like the thing about I've been
watching Chernobyl and that show would
be great for reactions because it just
pulls so much out of you but at the same
time would be the weirdest show to do
reactions to and not that they're
similar but you know not that they're
similar but you know Watchmen I expect
be pretty grim and I feel like grim
things make for weird reactions oh my
god jiggly Shelly you're still alive I
remember you from like way way way way
way way back when dude Julie what's new
have not seen Umbrella Academy is this
live yes it is John Bailey is
pre-recorded let me go get the newspaper
I'm very excited for the new Christopher
Nolan movie hell yeah man it's
Christopher Nolan oh yeah I am excited
for the fact that it's going to film
eventually cast it they've been casting
it already
I think Robert Pattinson is in the - hey
hurts hurts oh Anderson I want to hug
you
Curt is our Nomad patron who just never
met he never asks for anything but he's
constantly showing support thanks dude
epic voice guy we haven't hung out in a
while John Bailey you can hang out again
soon
sheva 'the orgy with you and your wife
whoo yeah I think that's a bright idea I
feel like doing it with John Bailey
would lend itself to a wide variety of
feeling like you're doing it with
multiple people because you just keep
switching voices that happen if you
close your eyes just right all right
John we'll switch it up this is this
live stream is the definition of just
changing lighting as much as possible
working with conditions yeah that's how
we roll that's how we roll all right on
the okay Arthur Morgan said John Morse
it so enforced would you want a Roger
Robert - and if you would who would you
want to see I would want to see Roger
Rabbit and wreck-it Ralph combined ha ha
ha that would be really cool to me uh I
want to see Roger Rabbit and John wick
meet and yeah I have to do something
together Jenna how's it going my dear
evgeniy oh we got some top patrons here
thanks guys up team any thoughts on type
we we did cover that you are late to the
party here Breaking Bad ready to rabbit
good call good call favorite Nolan movie
I mean not including the dirt no yeah I
think inception is his best at combining
both elements of his you know reasons to
go to the theater with a cool story and
great characters inception to me is the
one yeah you know I think dunker again
and her seller accomplished a hell of a
lot on a technical achievement that I
mean inception is one that I'm
emotionally pulled in and also feel like
I'm be mind blown by yeah
prestige is a very underrated one John
and I once have a very long private
conversation about how that is so
underrated
very private oh thanks want some bread
new end New Zealand New Zealand fly the
comb coats you can't do that boys race
Jemaine congratulations on the new job
Jenna I'm sure I got a patron message
there from you hey Congrats I know you
were you were having an interview here
congratulations
worst ever movie theater experience all
right I got this one I got husband once
waiting in line for like six hours to
watch the Star Wars Episode three men I
feel that along this some of you guys
waited longer for stuff but there's
about six hours got off at school or
leading we got great seats as we were
front of the line we stood up for like a
second to just check out this others
second like a few of us to check out
this other site it was literally like
less than five seconds and some dude and
his family just took our seats and were
like no we were sitting there but we
were in eighth grade and this was like a
40 year old man he's like and he
literally had never forget it he's like
oh this is America patriotism that's we
[ __ ] said too much 8th graders how
about you left the seats thanks Cameron
it's really sweet any you guys you guys
who like endure these super chats I you
know I know that a lot of youtubers
Javas are doing these live streams and
stuff but when you guys show that
support like that it really means a lot
because
you're just showing your support
kindness of your own heart and money
means everything the the shallows all
day whoever asked that over the Meg like
in any old time let's see here
Cameron Renfro would would you rather
see Silver Surfer Adam warlock in
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 I wasn't
out to see Adam warlock because he is he
seems like he's the right one who has
been teased to be in guardians he was
teasing Guardians one of them one of the
many post-credit scenes and on top of
that - you know like we had the Infinity
Gauntlet pretty much adapted to the big
screen between a Finity warning game and
Adam warlock such a big part of that
feel like it just makes more sense to
have Adam warlock finally be introduced
yeah man into the MCU maybe Adam warlock
will come in at the same time that Black
Adam enters the DCU and then we'll have
a couple Adams rise of the Skywalker
predictions that are gonna do everything
right Skywalker eyes you know they're
gonna they're gonna say what it was a
room mad about in last Jedi Ray's dad
let's do it let's do is change it Snoke
was raised data and the Knights of Ren
are back but then kylo is gonna become
good and there's gonna be a force ghost
reunion the force ghost reunion I'm
gonna call the Jedi Skywalker's from now
on yeah thanks Jenna Oh Jenna you're so
sweet love my dear
now Thank You Jenna I love we love you
too there's a reason we love chatting
with you damn you to Dan Stevens for any
role they want to give him what is the
greatest movie going experience yes this
is not my favorite movie of all time but
the one that just where I really felt
like oh this is what it's like to be a
part of a fandom was the first Avengers
that was various but going on opening
night and being a part of the crowd to
that degree with just everyone cheering
and laughing and clapping throughout
I have never that was the first time
I've ever felt something like that for
just for a movie that anticipated and
for it to just hit like I was just
smiling the whole finale it was one of
the best experiences I've personally
ever had and what else to say killed
Volume one that was my first Tarantino
movie ever watched teenager and I had no
idea what I was watching it was actually
pretty terrifying to watch when you're
like 12 or 13 yeah I loved it I loved it
John what about you um definitely The
Dark Knight was one the fury road was
one that was pretty memorable I got see
Ed Wood on my birthday one year which
was one of my favorite like nostalgic
movie going experiences it was like a
film print and stuff and that time we
went to grind house when we met out was
he know that was special and actually
getting to see the the full cut the the
bloody affair cut of Kill Bill was
pretty special I'm 20 years old plus
four Carter Lovejoy thanks buddy
thank you so much don't we know a card
Lovejoy in person I feel like to do we
know a car we know a Lovejoy we known
cards so I think they're congealing how
about this for Disney and r-rated Mickey
Mouse raunchy comedy you mean like the
happy time burgers how well that one
open you know what actually dealt with
that I you know it makes a great trailer
I don't know make a good movie it would
make a good sketch a good sketch it
would make a really funny trailer but I
feel like the joke would get old really
fast
hmm do we get paid to review films or do
you have jobs outside we get paid
through Adsense this oh if assuming a
video is fun we get paid through there
Travis asked earlier what we do what we
did before we started making a living
off of reviews oh I had many jobs
immediately before this my like the
first what I was doing immediately
before this was I was a receptionist at
a at a general practice general family
practice at a doctor's office and then I
what I eventually quit to do YouTube
because there's a period of first few
years when I was doing this pretty much
on my own that's when I eventually get
some extra money going because it wasn't
like Oh BAM you know I started
YouTube just blew up it's like I left my
job after working on YouTube for about a
year and a half straight and then it was
just enough to make rent but then there
were some other bills I was also doing
some post mates but that was when I for
like two months when I was doing a
postman - three months - I was doing
post mates so yeah but before I've had a
lot of jobs vicious dogs there's a hot
dog cook I even still have a I still
have a hot dog named after me called the
greggy veggie at vicious dogs in North
Hollywood yeah that is me who invented
that John what about you or some of your
jobs uh I was an inter I got my like
movies start doing stuff for Fangoria
and like interning and stuff back in the
day that I worked at a coffee house that
did like movie screenings and stuff for
a really long time then I worked at Blum
house for a little while doing social
media when Blum house had a website and
you know I've had a few odd jobs here
and there since then I used to portable
makeup mirrors over the phone to people
and I used to teach improv comedy to
children and now we do this oh and I
worked haunted houses for a long time
and then well after John was fired from
sexually harassing jason blum that's
right don't worry I made my you gotta
make her move when you're in the man's
office and all kind of lined up John was
because John was kind of like we'd like
we started the channel together but then
he was in college and I was I was just a
little bit more into the channel at the
time so then eventually you know tom was
sort of like this glorified guest yeah
that's like essentially what it be known
as but then after he left plum house it
just felt right I was like what's
partner-up let's change some stuff
around the channel let's uh we could do
more reviews and we could do a little
more sketches and we could start patreon
page and stuff stuff yeah Suge Knight Oh
Greg have you watched Cobra Kai season
three yet no I don't think anyone else
know what torrents are you using season
two I have not seen it yeah thank you
for the super chat but yeah fortunate I
have not seen it yet
John is covering that over at our
patreon page we just had some issues
with
people at YouTube originals and YouTube
red when it came to wane so we're not
doing it over here so we're just doing
stream alongs there but because I was
already I'm already covering Gotham just
because of time and you know making sure
everything is flowing it was like it
only made sense that he could do with
that on his own so he's doing Cobra Kai
season 2 what do you think of Cobra Kai
season 2 I'm four episodes in and I'm
really enjoying it so far I mean it has
all the charms and all the sensibilities
that I loved so much about the first
season I've heard a couple complaints
than the action can get a little too big
I haven't encountered that yet but for
the most part I've been loving it I'm
really really satisfied
yeah it's because I'll be like editing
over there while he's filming here I'll
try not to hear what he's reviewing
because I'm gonna binge this on my own
time eventually yeah it's good it's good
what do you guys think about a game of
Thrones movie course-correction get JJ
Abrams in there let him fix everything
just just wait 15 years get the books
done and rebooted full metal style does
new location tour that's the sad part is
I would take you on a tour of this whole
place however the the signal from the
Ennis place is bigger so the signal from
the internet for some reason this setup
does not extend that much further past
the hallway yeah I would definitely
definitely lose connection right away
miss the Katie thank you so much are you
guys Bone Thugs and harmony or tec-9
fans and can you guys please react to
one day to this Smokey and the Bandit
the movie Smokey and the Bandit that's a
we actually do a movie Wow that's a task
right that is a task then we'd want to
make sure we really review it yeah
that's that's the that's the part about
us of where we get like a little daunted
to ask answer your question is the katie
is that this well sometimes uh well we
won't mind watching something the thing
is is like we know we're gonna like
though the longer a video is the more
we're gonna want to talk about it
meaning the more we're going to
it's still gonna want to do this and add
this and add this so mitten maybe a
bandit I haven't seen it know I've never
seen smoking the Bandit they're playing
in an AMC recently and I was thinking of
doing it that might be something more
down the road that we've we've
considered doing like audio commentaries
I got no people mainly want to watch us
do a reaction but sometimes it's like we
really like to just do like audio
commentary which I think would be a lot
of fun a commentary like a riff or
something as for the music I know Bone
Thugs and harmony and tec-9 both from
derated different things but I don't
know a heap ton of they're like
catalogues together I have like
scattered songs from each and tec-9 I
think was in question The Devil's
Carnival which was a follow up that the
people who made repo the Genetic Opera
made so there's that we go yeah we have
seen the Game of Thrones season a pitch
meeting I you know we do reactions to a
lot of things and even though we've done
a couple of reactions to the pitch
meeting I've just taken it upon myself
to there's only one one show on youtube
that ii there's a notification i watch
it right away or i wait this one
specifically I wait to watch my
girlfriend and that is Ryan George's
pitch meetings like the most beautiful
little nugget of joy Friday that will do
another reaction to them or maybe Joe
might because I I just that's become
like my thing
no I got just like we react to so many
things on YouTube but that's the one
YouTube channel like a yes I must watch
this on my own just keep it for myself I
mean I certainly wouldn't be opposed to
reacting to them cuz they make good
reactions but yeah for the most part I
like to enjoy them but everyone so I'm
down yeah
Alba are you guys Indian definitely is
somebody asked what's your ethnic
background is earlier Hyuna uh yeah I am
Filipino and Italian 70 actually guys
you should look up the DNA ancestry
results test if you really I I love that
video that was that was a lot of fun to
put together we did I react I like we
did the whole thing
the DNA like put all the spin in blah
blah blah then we let me picked up
filming and once the results came in
that was a really fun video to put
together and reacting to our results was
a total blast so I would love it if you
guys want to go check that yeah but uh
conflict of interest but if you want to
get a DNA test get some of that
MyHeritage going go after Eurovision
video cuz we got discounts on there
oh thanks The Price is Right review yo
yo sup guys always enjoy your reactions
keep it up thanks so much thanks dude
I'm assuming you have reviews yourself
it's in your name I hope yeah a lot of
people have a title they have no videos
maybe you just reviews The Price is
Right episodes uh yeah we've seen I saw
the first midsummer trailer I did like
that one nataliya dad did like that one
I think a Kingdom Hearts movie would get
out of hand but I think it would be a
neat universe to someday realize Disney
loves to play with all their toys in
unison if wreck-it Ralph - proved us
anything we don't smoke but we in just a
lot of other drugs like usually in the
morning take some adderall some coke and
then when you go into bed it's good to
take some shrooms so you can really have
some good dreams yeah and the middle of
the day just depending on the mood just
shoot some heroin man mmm
John's murder heroin good yeah
oh yeah touch my head so really really
slows down a lot of product we get a lot
more done actually Greg and Olivia met
like he saw her and he was like okay
dude I gotta win this chick but I don't
have any confidence so what he had me do
is I pretended to kidnap her and then
Greg save me yeah but the problem is
she's really tough and she just beat the
[ __ ] out of me and then they started
talking so Scott gonzo thanks buddy we
will be reviewing your talk about the
original Godzilla the one from a few
years ago or one yeah which one are you
talking about because we are planning on
reviewing Godzilla king of the monsters
next week so hell yeah I best look out
for that one Andrew thanks dude
I hope to see martial-arts combat and
the new Matt Reeves like in the BDS
where a senior thoughts of Batman combat
skills on big screen yes I mean what
I've I think it was I believe it was the
third trailer for BBS where we were they
teased the warehouse fight and I was
flipping out watching that because I
didn't know they were gonna bring that
level of martial arts skill to Batman
because Batman is a martial artist you
gotta have the hand-to-hand combat and
especially with what we get in movies
like John wick today like an American
cinema Keanu Reeves Bruce Wayne my
brother and I we really grew up on like
Hong Kong cinema and so we're big fans
of fight choreography especially where
it's not like a bunch of crazy editing
which is one of the main reasons I
really admire the John wick fighting
style too but for Batman absolutely yes
they if they don't have that I will be
very very disappointed like include the
detective element please but if you
don't have that the insane martial arts
fights at least one or two I'm gonna be
really upset about that that's one thing
I definitely want if all the Batman
films I've seen I've never seen one that
has like truly breathtaking hand-to-hand
combat and yeah I would love to see it
and I know this suit kind of makes that
tricky sometimes but I would love to see
that yeah well I'm kind of hoping they
dumb down the suit yeah like I think
i'ma get a little bit of a classic like
Batman animated series suit I mean I
highly doubt they're gonna do that but
something that makes it look like he's
more mobile something where he can
easily looks like oh yeah he can
definitely move in that you know
something that's like he is he is just a
dude yeah have a utility belt what you
have some [ __ ] yeah as a post it makes
more sense in real life to have a suit
that can probably handle like a knife
stabbed or some bullets or something
like that
however I will remember like the Batman
vs predator short film yeah that's very
old-school something like that but more
modern okay yeah I'm down I'm down up
Sam Garcia thank you so much does dark
fates feel similar to genis Dennis ice
I'm going to keep da do you think this
one first I've talked
I from hearing some people talk about
the trailer specifically I I get the
ways in which it kind of has some of
those I mean there are things in the
trailer that remind me a little of
salvation and Genesis so I don't think
the comparison is unfounded and going by
the trailer and the fact that it is it
does seem to be focused on the spectacle
whereas what I've heard the footage
they've shown is more you know character
oriented I don't think the movie will be
as much like Genesis if luck is you know
good but I don't think that it's a bad
comparison at this moment if you guys
have not seen the Variety interview the
45-minute interview with James Cameron
and Tim Miller were they they go into
depth on the process and the pre
approach and then the way they worked
through the script for like a year or
something like that I think it would
give you guys a lot more faith they're
well aware of how the other ones turned
out and and like there's so many reasons
I was sold on it from hearing that and I
don't feel like the teaser it's a teaser
trailer and you got to think about a lot
of things like dude there's a teaser
trailer give you give me was I like a
hundred percent satisfied with it no I
didn't like the plain sequence mm-hmm
you know I'm not really I feel like a
lot of people are pretty bummed about
not really getting much Arnold in it for
some reason I'm not really like yeah I
expect Arnold I did I want to see go
into Hamilton really I have a lot of
faith in the people working on this I
mean we talked about in our trailer
review which I know most people click
off after the reactions done but in the
they have a everyone who's working on
this is on this project for the right
reason so it's all on this because of
the fact of how passionate they are
about it Tim Miller has many options
after Deadpool two was done he
specifically chose this project because
they talked a lot about it was fastening
about that interview is they were
interviewing I think it was like
physicists and people who are really
studying the advancement of artificial
intelligence because they wanted to go
back to infusing some real-world stuff a
lot of what made Terminator 1 and
Terminator 2 really cool was how a lot
of that seems to be coming
there was an element of science to the
science fiction first to whereas the
later ones just go mostly for the
fiction and I think because of the fact
that it's a teaser trailer they're
trying to show stuff that would be
appealing to a bunch of audiences yeah
you know like let's show some fight
scenes and show some action but you know
I think that they're gonna I I have a
lot more faith in it a Tim Miller has
heavily emphasized like how his favorite
genres action sorry Tim Miller has
heavily emphasized his favorite genres
action and that he what he mean what he
really wants to make sure of is that
you're invested in the characters before
you know the crazy spectacle starts
going down he really cares heavily about
that so like I'm sold on it and I have a
lot of faith in it and I'm really okay
myself out there like no I have this is
the last time I will be this cautious
yeah this is if this does not turn out
well is the last time we're going to be
like all right and it's the last time
I'll trust it when James Cameron's like
no this movie that I didn't direct is
great you can see he's pointing out
Sarah Connor Chronicles and one of the
main writers of this is a guy who I
think he created he didn't create he
definitely was one of the VIII main
writers on this on this movie Carter
here we go
what's your MCU fantastic for Dreamcast
I love John Krasinski and Emily Blunt as
Reed Richards and Sue Storm that seems
to be the pick that everyone has right
at is the go-to pick that is like V go
to pick didn't we answer this one I feel
like we have I feel like we've done it
at least not a silly away on the top of
my head seriously I guess I would say
you know what I'll give it to you I'll
give joggers in skåne Emily left but I
feel like it would be really fun to see
them in those roles I just wonder if
you'd be a distraction it could I think
it could be for sure thing who would you
think yeah not Dwayne Johnson uh get
Dave Bautista yes personality I think I
think John Cena would be a good pair
thinking I think John seemed to be a
really good pick for the thing
for you know who would actually if I
didn't do the job doesn't see him Lee
blood thing I was looking Emily Blunt I
would love to see oh my god his name is
totally in my mind that they do [ __ ]
guy from goddamn what's his name what's
the property people versus OJ predator
Alana Oh Brian Terry Henry no no oh oh
oh [ __ ] look he's Stanfield
no no the guy who daughter Elena says
the F word the whole time [ __ ] yeah Oh
sterling K browser Lee K Brown Atlanta
but he's not know his Brian's hairy head
right no okay I thought he was I've ever
seen L Lana I thought it was on that
certainly K Brown yeah I think Stern
okay be a really cool Reed Richards
actually and I would love to who are we
missing
Oh doctor do in this storm Scott dam
Human Torch Human Torch who would be a
fun human could be funny but also but
also cool yeah who's funny and cool and
and appropriately aged for this yeah Oh
John it's rules is already an MCU cared
that's right he's in black panther oh
yeah that's right I guess I great gusted
oh me too daunting for people but I
would like to see Grant Gustin his human
torched he's perfectly likable yeah ray
gobo hey guys or get gebel uh hey guys
great channel I love your movie reviews
and reactions and I agree about the
whole Batman thing I'm a huge Batman fan
thank you so much thank you much
appreciative a we just did a podcast
video podcast with that Omnimedia go
check out his channel and one thing we
talked about was how I would love to see
some like solo origin movies of you know
two ways to approaches you do solo
origin movies of some Batman villains
or you have like a bunch of Batman
villains and like certain movies right
you haven't gone there that and then
eventually you do a movie where all the
villains team up but you don't see Bruce
Wayne in it all you do is you you treat
your villains as they're the protagonist
and that Batman is the villain and
they're all working together to try to
take down Batman but you treat Batman
like he's the villain okay that would be
a really cool Batman movie down the road
experimental [ __ ] I don't know if it'll
ever happen
Thank You Jay Michaels thanks for both
of those Michael J Michael J's oh I
think Ansel Elgort might be a nice human
sport yeah he's got a nice charisma
aboot him somebody wanted to know what
you think the rise of Skywalker Rotten
Tomatoes score will be rises Skywalker
though I'm more fascinated with that
audience scores yeah 35% that one I'm
much more interested in see what turns
out I'm going with 88 Critic 75 audience
I don't know 73 another it's obviously
easier to predict this [ __ ] when you
watch the movie yeah and we have known
each other since the first grade
whoever asked first grade first grade
really point you can really revamp a lot
of how what the future the holds because
the thing about that's that like
salvation lend itself to was well John
Connor is a hero right things have to
play out a certain way I think I don't
know the whole John Connor thing has
never made any sense to me two times of
like how sperm into a time travel
because in genesis more than if there's
one thing Genesis did was shine a light
on how much that doesn't make sense
yeah because clearly John Connor was
born in the 90s or something right or
whatever right John collee in the
original timeline before any Terminator
was sent back to try to kill Sarah
Connor that the way it works so they're
at Connor met someone or married
whatever right had a baby named John
Connor
John Connor eventually became the the
leader of the resistance down that road
of being the leader of the resistance a
child
born when John Connor was an adult this
child was named Kyle Reese calories grew
up became a part of the resistance
looked up to John Connor
eventually when a terminator was sent
back John Connor sent man much younger
than himself
Connor is back in time and then Kyle
Reese essentially [ __ ] up the whole
thing impregnated Sarah Connor uh and
then Sarah Connor was like uh maybe
you're John Connor you're gonna be this
guy like that's not the same John Connor
though I always thought it'd be cool to
if you were gonna bring back John Connor
to do something where you get like
whoever John Connor is to have this
epiphany and go wait a minute
I'm not that John Connor who sent back
Kyle Reese I'm a total evil the other
guy Sean can't have the same mom but a
different dad every time you send
somebody back this timeline I think it
would be really really cool to explore
that and like see what that means in
terms of destiny see what that means for
that John Connor character like them
whenever furlong was playing so where
that goes
we did see Bradford we're gonna shoot
her if you defer tomorrow I'll be up on
Sunday and whoever I do spoilers for
that one yeah whoever asked much-loved
to the red letter media that was one of
our favorite mutually favorite channels
red letter media they're their thing
they're the guys who can get away with
saying anything like they live the dream
they have noses like once a month
they're not they don't have to be
careful about the saying [ __ ] like that
it's crazy how they can literally like
they can love something or hate
something and then it's like you know
depending on what the popular opinion is
if we sway the opposite like us or most
YouTube channels dislike dislike hate
hate hate red letter media is a [ __ ]
massacre there don't even like care to
be like super like let me make sure I'm
really articulating this and make sure
I'm not you know piss pissing off anyone
we'll just be super blunt and like they
can get away with it they're they're one
of the best channels ever I don't
freestyle rap very often Greg is much
better at freestyling than me I'm much
better in the written space for for
rapping and I don't want to see Kit
Harington play John Khan
I love that they're making a salami well
that's the other thing too is I feel
like you can also I don't know there are
some times when casting is also like a
cue because you can tell when people are
putting popular people into roles versus
actually casting for it's like genesis
part of the reason that movie kind of
irked me was that I could feel them
casting on two popular marketable people
rather than who's good for these roles
but yeah Greg freestyle rap rivals right
yeah once I stopped stopped you know
once I stopped the persona that would
totally get me tweeted at every [ __ ]
day nope can't do it anymore
lost it Amy you did a spider been
drawing we got to see it do I need do I
have I seen this make sure I see it
somehow anyway guys we're gonna log off
right about now I want to thank everyone
who has contributed to super Chad you
guys are from very like that seriously
you don't pull all right well that's
right weren't Renfro
what do you guys think about a family
we're taking on the five families of
Gotham before wait what what do you guys
think about a Batman movie taken on the
five families of Gotham before any super
villains
so just Batman versus the crime I think
that would work world I think you know
it would be good to help keep it the
prom you running through with a solo
Batman movie is will the villain
outshine Batman you know like the 1989
Batman like will you run into that
problem and I feel like if you were to
focus on that it would help with just
keeping the focus on defining Batman and
there because the Batman super villains
I think out of any DC character his row
gallery is probably just as popular as a
most of the heroes oh yeah specific
characters that are on gala I mean
everyone's like heard of Riddler Joker
twoface mainly Catwoman like you've
heard all scarecrow now is an IV like
you've heard of all these characters and
so it's easy to lend yourself to a to a
territory like the idea of hearing that
penguin and Catwoman are rumored to be
villains in this New Madrid movie
actually I never talked we haven't
talked about that does not excite me
because I feel like that would totally
steal focus from reintroducing a Batman
and so I the idea I haven't heard this
five families rumor but I feel like that
would be cool mm-hm that would be their
Britney and that would be an interesting
way to shine a new light and if we're
talking about a Batman movie that is
more on the detective and is more in the
grounded physical realm I think that
could actually be a great way to you
know do something new with that yeah big
screen in anyway so yeah well thank you
thank you
quick shout out to everyone who has
contributed to the super chat today
Cameron Renfro Jay Michaels Rago Bill
Carter Lovejoy Sam Garcia Andrew Scott
Scott gonzo the price is right for you
miss Kat Katie was more people than ever
yeah three-two-three car Lovejoy Jenna
Randolph want some bread Kurt Anderson
ganja sorrows thank you guys so much and
thank you to everyone who has been
tuning in to this live stream if you're
just now tuning and go back and watch it
from the beginning this was a lot of fun
and you know this might be the format we
do it's actually a lot of fun to have an
open chat here about a movie news and
stuff or predictions and everything this
thank you because you guys thank you to
all the subscribers all the fans of this
channel
everyone is was you guys are the reason
we exist yeah thank you guys come on
please I want you so much thank you much
love we're gonna go back to editing some
stuff take care you have a great night
how do you I forget how to end this on
the phone okay is that the ex hit the ex
John alright bye much love peace